AP News officials Saudi tells U.S that
Iran May attack the kingdom Saudi Arabia
had shared has shared intelligence with
American officials that suggests Iran
could be preparing for an imminent
attack on the kingdom three U.S
officials said Tuesday the heightened
concerns about a potential attack on
Saudi Arabia come as the Biden
Administration is criticizing Tehran for
its Crackdown on widespread protests and
condemning it for sending hundreds of
drones as well as technical support to
Russia for use in its war in Ukraine the
U.S and Saudis blamed Iran in 2019 and
being behind a major attack in eastern
Saudi Arabia which helped the oil Rich
Kingdom production and cause energy
price to spike so this this leak of
information from Saudis to U.S
who's who's uh who's it does it seem
like Saudis are concerned that this
could backfire on them what's the motor
behind this time how do you process this
I I process it that you know if you're a
bullying on the playground sometimes you
say he hit me first and I I wonder if
this is kind of a little false flag that
the Saudis are putting up and the Saudis
but if you want to look up the Q rating
for the Saudis
probably probably just like it's gonna
be hired in irondo
for sure but you know what's interesting
they were only 99 hated by the news
media so I want to know the one guy that
that uh that wouldn't vote on that
um the I I think what's going on is the
Saudis are playing this game there's a
chess game and the Saudis are playing a
game here and I think they're trying to
throw some shade on Iran and and take
advantage of the the upheaval and stuff
that's in Iran and I think when people
you know you read your morning newspaper
and you and you look at stuff and you
have to look at the you know what does
the chessboard look behind this and this
is just a statement nothing has happened
this is a statement Tyler you got
thoughts on this
I well go ahead I just sent you
something so I want you to pull the
other day I was breaking that another
girl was killed in Iran uh Iran and I
think it's they might do something just
to draw a distraction away from the
protests and the rights I think they're
trying to get people's eyes off the
rights and the protests and let this
cool down while they go in and and
forcibly injure a lot of people and they
send the for the military in and quell
this and I think they're trying to do
something like draw distraction and and
actually I think they will do a small
attack in Saudi Arabia but again I think
it's just a distraction to to draw away
from the protests and the riots Adam
I sent you something it's it's actually
kind of gives you a more of a clearer
picture on what's happening in the
Middle East it's not so much Iran uh and
Saudi Arabia you know Sunni Shiite we've
all if you're not familiar with that
that's a whole we can go down the whole
Rabbit Hole there but it's sort of like
a a meme and it's two Arab guys kind of
talking and trying to figure it out and
basically goes like this in the middle
in the Middle East today we have the
sunnis who hate the Shia it's right and
then you have the Turks who hate the
Kurds and the Saudis hate the Iranians
and the Palestinians who hate the
Israelis and the yemenis who hate the
Saudis and the Iraqis who hate the
Iranians and the libyans who hate the
Egyptians so the cause of tension the
Middle East is clear and it could not be
clear it's failure of American
leadership
that's what it is so it's like if you
want to go down the rabbit hole of
what's going on in the Middle East it's
like we just cleared it up yeah
America's fault print this is Fault yeah
you know I mean you lived in Iran so I
think you can appreciate this it's like
it's not all just Arabs are together and
they hate us faster and they hate you
know Israel there's there's Sunni and
their Shiites and obviously the Turks
and the Armenians have their issues and
Azerbaijan and Russia and this and the
old Cold War and who came in and the
Egyptians they have peace with with
Israel and the jordanians like I think
um Netanyahu who's all up in the news
running for re-election for like the
fifth all of them all up in it yeah um
first of all this artist everybody looks
like Osama Bin Laden I don't know every
single person but somebody asked me the
other day why like why are Middle East
is why you guys have so much like you
know how hot it is can you imagine going
to the beach and never leaving it's just
hot people are angry dude it's hot well
I live in Miami it's just as hot and
nobody no but there's no shade bro these
guys are out in the middle of the
freaking desert bro there's an angry and
hot I don't understand Israel and
starters dude secret relationship well
they can afford the air conditioning
here's something that I think they built
an island that looks like a map of the
world yes they were bored we have all
this money spent in what country is that
Dubai Dubai yeah I mean they're just
doing their dividers like we can make it
rain here go ahead what if you put a
palm tree next to it we'll build that
next just to kind of go on the Israel
perspective about Bibi he was on Bill
Maher recently he you know he was on Fox
recently I I like BB a lot
um he said for years and years and years
he kind of threw John Kerry under the
bus here under the Obama Administration
he's like for years and years and years
and years as they're saying if you want
to have peace in the Middle East and
peace with your Arab neighbors you have
to start with the Palestinians you have
to start there and you make peace there
and he's like listen they don't want
peace okay so he goes listen I I don't
not going to make peace with the one
percent and then move on to the 99 he
basically said let me go make peace and
deals with the 99 Arab world and you
look what they've done with all the
arrangements and peace treaties whether
it's Egypt Jordan UAE Oman everything
that they've done he's like let me make
peace with the 99 and then we'll go back
to the one percent I thought that was a
very unique perspective because you
constantly hear about
Israel and Palestinians and figuring it
out it's like where's that gotten
anything and he said listen let's move
the ball forward with the rest of the
Arab countries let's make friends you
know we have a lot of common interests a
lot of their common interests have to do
with you know versus Iran everything
against Iran preventing Iran from a
nuclear weapon forget preventing
terrorism in the Middle East and part of
that is this story right here where this
secret relationship between Israel and
Saudi because what's the famous thing we
always talk about the friend or the
enemy of my enemy is my friend everyone
can agree that Iran is pretty much
everyone's enemy in the Middle East
other than certain parts of Syria and
Hezbollah and Lebanon and that kind of
stuff like that Afghanistan but well
well that's a whole nother thing but uh
interesting perspective by Bibi let's
see what happens there's a lot of
tension right now we'll see what
happened here so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign